>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Sandra Charles: OK.
Good morning.
In the interest of time and to
respect those of you who are here
on time, I'd like to
begin our program.
We're being videotaped and so
I would like also to make sure
that we can get the full benefit
of the resources available to us.
I'm Sandra Charles, the library's
physician and Chief of the Office
of Occupational Medicine
and Health Services.
And through the core activities
of that office, we exemplify
and give support to the library's
strategic objectives empowering the
workforce, capitalizing
on collaborations,
and leveraging the strength of
diversity in the library's staff,
collections, and constituents.
And I say that because
today's program is sort
of a coalition of all those things.
Our health and wellness program
is one of the core activities
that we have, one of the
more pleasant core activities
that we have.
And we see it as a
public health function
where we're serving a
population, the library staff,
and we focus on enhancing
staff engagement,
wellness, and productivity.
We're not a very large staff.
There are about seven of us and if
there are any health services staff
in the room would you please stand?
Please? OK.
And I think they're only
two missing [laughing].
But all that being said,
though we are a small staff,
we have strong support from
our divorce partnerships
that we have both within
and outside of the library.
And here in the library, the Library
of Congress Professional
Association, LCPA,
and other staff organizations
as well
as our two year old wellness advisor
committee have been really strong
supporters not to mention
several other office and staff --
offices and staff from
across the service units.
For example, we have our chair of
the wellness advisor committee,
Wauneta Lyle, a cancer
survivor and a staunch
and passionate advocate of wellness.
She'll be giving our closing.
And the series that we
advertise, the Brown Bag Series
for Living Well, that we do jointly
with LCPA, was her brain child.
We also have with us
today and the person
who will be introducing our
speaker is Maureen Cohen Harrington,
an associate general
counselor here at the library.
She's also a member
of the advisory board
for the Congressional
Vegetarian Staff Association,
which is also represented
here today.
Adam. And she's an
avid in-line skater.
So I thought she's a perfect role
model for the emphasis we're putting
on both eating well and good
nutrition and physical fitness.
And I must say, before I
ask Maureen to come forward,
that I see this coalition as
what really makes us strong.
So I would say we are a small,
but mighty force for health
and wellness, or, in
Jamaican parlance,
we're little, but tallawah.
So [laughing] without
further ado, Maureen,
which you come forward please
to introduce our speaker.
>> Maureen Cohen Harrington:
There is a dignified way to get
up to the stage and
I [inaudible] it.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Charles
and, to clarify,
I'm Assistant General Counsel.
You gave me a promotion,
but thank you [laughing].
Um, I am thrilled to
welcome Dr. Neal Barnard here
to the Library of Congress.
Many thanks to all of you for
joining us especially to those
of you who had to walk
a few buildings over.
Um, Dr. Barnard is Adjunct
Associate Professor of Medicine
at the George Washington
University School
of Medicine and Health Sciences.
He's President of the Physicians
Committee for Responsible Medicine.
He's founder of the non-profit
Barnard Medical Center here in DC.
He's the author of more than
70 scientific publications
and 18 books including several on
the New York Times Best Seller List.
And he's got a stockpile of other
accomplishments too numerous
to mention here or
even in the program,
which does go into some more detail.
But what I admire about Dr. Barnard
is that he's at the forefront
of a groundbreaking
and, in some ways,
very simple approach to medicine.
His work shows that
our diets can prevent
and sometimes even reverse many
serious health conditions including
heart disease and some of the others
that he'll be discussing here today.
We at the Congressional Vegetarian
Staff Association have been lucky
to have Dr. Barnard at some of our
events so I can personally vouch
for what a terrific speaker he is.
In case you're wondering how I
ended up on the advisory board
of the Congressional
Staff Association,
the CVSA decided a few years
ago to welcome its members --
among its membership library staff.
So, if you're interested in
learning more about the group,
please speak with me or to Adam
Sarvana, our President, over there.
And now it's my pleasure to
turn this over to our wonderful
and distinguished speaker,
Dr. Barnard.
[ Applause ]
>> Neal Barnard: Thank you.
Thank you.
Well, thank you.
And thanks to all of you for coming.
You know, when I was a
medical student at GW,
we talked about heart disease,
but it was a one way street.
You know what I'm talking about?
You'll get this disease,
you'll never get rid of it,
and it wasn't just heart disease.
Diabetes was that way.
Once you had diabetes,
you'll always have diabetes.
And what problems were
like that too.
You might lose a little
bit of weight,
but overall these things were
regarded as progressive conditions
that just don't get better.
But we've started to see that
there's a very different way
of dealing with these diseases
and that's why I've called this
lecture Reversing Heart Disease.
Just so that we're all on the same
page about what we're talking about,
garden variety heart disease is
in the coronary arteries so --
they're called coronary arteries
because they crown the heart and,
if you look -- can you see this OK?
OK. So the coronary arteries are
there to provide blood and oxygen
for the heart muscle and the heart
muscle can't work unless it gets a
good blood supply.
But over time, for a lot of
people, this nice wide open artery
at the top gets gradually clogged
and these blockages can
rupture and cause blood clot.
And that's like a cork
in a -- in a bottle.
It just stops blood flow.
And back in 1990, Dr. Dean Ornish
-- is that a familiar name?
Dean Ornish won -- he was -- he was
quite a young doctor at the time.
He said, "I want to see if we can
actually make this disease go away."
In other words he didn't want
to just try to prevent it
in people who didn't have it.
He went into hospitals in
the San Francisco Bay area,
he brought in people
who had heart disease,
and wanted to see what he could do.
So he -- he used an experimental
program, had four parts.
The first part was vegetarian foods.
Now, why would you use
vegetarian foods in heart patients?
Why? Why would you do that?
OK. Low fat, high in
fiber, no cholesterol.
That's right.
OK. Secondly, half
hour walk every day.
Third, manage stress, which
is why he didn't do the study
and Washington, D.C.
[ Laughing ]
Avoid tobacco.
And that was the whole program.
There was no medication
used, no surgery, nothing.
And he had a comparison group that
followed regular medical advice.
And after a year, their total
cholesterol dropped 24%.
LDL, is that familiar?
Bad cholesterol.
Dropped 37%.
That's the kind of thing
that we use medications for.
It happened just from diet change.
But what got everybody's
attention was
that they lost 22 pounds on average.
If they were already skinny,
they didn't lose any weight,
but if they were heavy,
they lost a lot of weight.
And the average what loss
was 22 pounds in the year
without even counting calories.
However, what made medical
history was something different.
Everyone had an angiogram.
An angiogram is a special
x-ray of the heart.
It shows the little
trickle of blood that gets
through to the heart muscle.
And they compared the results at the
end to the results at the beginning,
the angiogram at the beginning.
And you could see that the arteries,
instead of getting narrower
and narrower, were
actually opening up again.
And the patients felt it because
their chest pain was gone usually
within four or five, six weeks.
And at the end of a year, you
could see miserable changes
in 82% of the participants.
No surgery.
No drugs. Just these simple, cheap,
low-tech interventions with diet
and exercise and so forth.
And then what got the insurance
companies' attention was,
do you have to go back
to the hospital?
Do we need to operate on you?
Or do you die?
And the control group,
not doing so hot.
But the intervention
group had a dramatic drop.
So this really changed
medical history.
And now Medicare says,
"You want this program?
We'll pay for it," because it --
it's the best investment
that they can make.
So heart disease is
not a one-way street.
It's a two-way street.
But it won't be a two-way street
unless we make the kinds of changes
that it takes to actually
take those clogged arteries
and open them up again.
We thought that was kind
of a heroic thing to do
and it is unless you
follow the simple things
that your body needs
to regain its health.
OK. So are there other parts of the
body that need healthy arteries?
Are there?
Like? Oh, the brain!
Yes. This underused organ, um, does
need some -- I mean this year --
but the carotid artery
goes up and then it splits.
Part of it goes to the outside
and part of it goes inside
and you can have blockages
there too.
Meaning, you may not have a heart
attack, you might have a stroke.
OK? Um, do we have
arteries elsewhere?
Sure we do.
Um, the lower back.
You know anybody who's
got chronic back pain?
Um, researchers in Scandinavia
did the most amazing thing.
They started looking at
autopsies of people who had --
who had died after having had back
pain for a long period of time.
And they found a couple of things,
that -- let me show you this.
If you have back pain, you've got --
do you see the bony vertebrae there?
That's the tan part.
Those are bones that --
one on top of the other.
And between them, the purple
part, those are disks.
They're like little
cushions between.
So they keep the bones from
bashing into each other.
Well, those cushions, at
the top, that's normal.
But you see, if you look down here,
you see that kind of
thing ballooning out?
That's that cushion.
It's like the stuffing's coming
out of that cushion and it presses
on a nerve and that nerve is
running all the way down your leg
and so you get what
they call sciatica.
My -- my back is killing me.
My legs are killing me.
And it's pressure on that nerve.
The Scandinavian researchers
found, if you looked at smokers,
they had a lot more of
these degenerated disks.
Why? Smoke -- cigarettes
aren't heavy.
OK? So it couldn't be that.
What is it?
And they decided here's what it is.
If you look at the arteries
-- this is the aorta.
There's the heart and the aorta
comes off and then it loops down
and it goes all the way down
and right in front of your spine
and it gives off vertebral
arteries to every vertebral segment.
And the very first place where
the arteries are damaged,
right where they -- where
they start to narrow,
is the vertebral arteries
right in the abdominal aorta.
So you could be 18 years old
and your heart's maybe OK,
but you start losing those arteries.
And so the lower back isn't
getting blood supply anymore --
or not getting very much.
And so then if you have a
trauma on the football field
or you got rear-ended
in your car or whatever,
the back can't heal anymore.
And those disks become fragile and
they start to herniate and it's
because of a lack of blood flow.
Normally your back should be able to
have a little bit of wear and tear,
but it can't anymore because
of a lack of blood flow.
Is this making sense?
So, researchers now think that
lower back pain is, in many cases,
not just trauma or bad luck,
but in some cases it's a
sign of bad blood flow.
OK. Surprising?
Um, are there other parts of the
body that need good blood flow?
One of the most popular pills
at the pharmacy is this one.
All Viagra does -- the only
thing it does is cause arteries
to open up a little bit.
And the reason is that the
male sexual anatomy is sort
of a hydraulic system that
needs good blood flow in order
to work properly if you
catch what I'm getting at.
And so we see, in our research
center, a lot of people
with erectile dysfunction.
But when they follow the Ornish
type of diet, plant based diet,
blood flow opens up again in
the heart and after two or three
or four months, I cannot
tell you how many men come in
and say, "My nature is back."
So. Anyway.
A lot of people are going vegan
because it's this macho diet.
Right? So, anyway.
There you go.
OK. So we talked about getting
away from the animal products.
Animal products are the
only source of cholesterol.
There's no cholesterol in a bean
or a grain of rice or a sprig
of broccoli or an apple or
-- plant foods don't have it.
But there's a lot of it in
meat, dairy products, eggs,
and they also have the bad fat,
saturated fat, that causes your body
to make more cholesterol.
OK? Which leads us to the
question of, OK, I believe it.
You know. I'm sure if I
were vegan, I'd do great.
I'd be slim.
I'd be healthier.
But, wait a minute.
Can I do this?
Do any of you feel that
sometimes foods might be a little
bit addictive?
You know, there's -- even if
we'd like to change our diet,
we think, I don -- I don't know.
I'm not sure I can do it.
What is the most addictive food?
At the University of Michigan, 2015,
researchers asked this question.
What is your most addictive food?
And what they meant was which
foods give you a problem?
You've already eaten enough,
but you just can't resist.
They had 384 people.
Which foods do you just
find yourself eating more
than you want to?
You can't cut down.
You lose control.
Well, number five was ice cream.
You know what I'm talking about.
I'm not hungry, but I
just want the taste.
Number four, cookies.
Number three, chips.
Number two, chocolate.
And number one --
>> Cheese.
>> Neal Barnard: Pizza.
And who said cheese?
I'm going to say it's
not the olives.
Right? I don't think it's
the sun dried tomatoes.
I don't think it's even the crust.
I think it's that half
inch of yellow asphalt
over the top of our -- cheese.
Is this making sense?
Um, we love cheese.
It doesn't love us back, but
people get hooked on this.
And I am going to argue
that cheese is fattening,
that it is a little bit addicting,
and causes health problems.
And I'd like to just spend a couple
of minutes on -- on some of this.
Um, what causes our weight problems?
Um, a lot of people say it's this.
Right? Sugar.
I'm going to raise a
question mark about that.
I'm going to suggest for a
second that soda is health food,
but if you look at the trend over
time, sweeteners went up until 1999
at which point people
discovered bottled water.
And that started cutting
into the sweeteners --
the soda market in a serious way.
And sugar consumption has been
dropping for almost 20 years.
But cheese has been going up.
And where's obesity?
It's going right along with cheese.
OK? So back in 1909 when the USDA
started tracking America's cheese
consumption, we really did
not eat very much of it.
It was kind of a European thing.
And in Perioria, you know,
we're not going to eat more --
we couldn't eat more than four
pounds of cheese in a year.
But two things happened.
Fast food chains found that
burgers had to have cheese on top.
And so cheese started
making more and more inroads
and then pizza chains came in and,
at first, it was a sprinkling.
Then it was a layer.
And then it was a couple layers.
And now, actually I should
update this, in 2017,
the average American consumes
35 pounds of cheese every year.
That's 60,000 calories worth
of cheese every single year.
Am I cheering you up?
Um, it's loaded with calories.
And where are the calories?
This will be -- this will be
on the test -- very important.
For -- a gram of sugar
has only four calories.
And that's true not just of
sugar, but any carbohydrate.
So you have friends who
say, "Don't eat potatoes.
They're fattening."
Right? Any carbohydrate,
whether it's potatoes or bread
or fruit sugar, has only
four calories in a gram.
But a gram of fat has nine calories.
So if a person's trying to lose
weight, skipping the chicken fat,
and the beef fat, and the cheese
fat causes weight loss much faster
than trying to not eat bread.
OK? All right.
Um, the leanest beef
is about 29% fat.
Chicken is not a lot different, 23%.
Fish are -- they vary,
some lower, some higher.
But then if you look at something
like broccoli or beans or rice
or sweet potatoes, not only do they
have no cholesterol, they are very,
very low in fat and
that's why people
who consume these foods
tend to be slim.
They tend to lose weight.
All right.
Cheese, however.
Seventy percent fat.
If it were any worse,
it would be Vaseline.
Very, very high in fat.
And there is Coke Zero, but
there is no Cheddar Zero.
So there is really no
super dietetic cheese.
Um, sodium content is
an interesting thing.
People are concerned about
sodium for a couple reasons.
What -- what does sodium
do in the body?
OK. So your blood pressure
will go up.
It also cause you to lose
a little bit of calcium.
But if you have a lot of salt in
your diet, you'll keep water weight
and you'll feel bloated
and boggy and crummy.
So an orange has about
a milligram of sodium.
An apple has two and a brown rice
has 20 and a potato has about 13.
Potato chips, 330, two ounces
of cheddar, 350, Edam, 500,
and Velveeta, 800 milligrams
of sodium!
They add it.
They add it in the -- in the
dairy because they add more sodium
and that stops the bacterial
action from over fermenting cheese.
So it's a very, very,
very high sodium food.
And so why is it fattening?
It's high in calories.
The food fat adds to body
fat -- I didn't mention this.
Um, if you eat carbohydrate, like
bread, in theory you could make fat
out of it, but it's really
hard for your body to do.
If you eat bread, your body takes
the bread and pulls the carbohydrate
out and breaks that into sugar
molecules that go into the blood
and those sugar molecules power your
brain and they power your muscles.
They don't go to fat.
But you eat two slices and three
slices, you eat half the loaf, well,
eventually your body will say,
"I don't need this much sugar,"
and it will store it in your liver
as something called glycogen.
Have you heard of this?
People who run marathons, they eat
lots of carbs leading up to the race
because they want to have glycogen
in their liver and their muscles.
It's like spare batteries.
It's not fat.
It's energy.
And you say, "OK.
I'm going to eat two
loaves of bread.
Can I eventually get
fat out of this?"
Yes, you can.
If you eat way more than your
body can store, you'll make fat
out of it, but even doing,
to turn a bread molecule
into a fat molecule burns up about
a quarter of all of its calories.
So it's very hard to gain weight
on a high carbohydrate diet unless
you add the cheese and the meat
to it because your body can take the
fat out of those and put it straight
into your body fat with
almost no conversion.
All right.
So fat slows down your metabolism.
It doesn't have any fiber at all.
Cheese has no fiber to control
your appetite and it's got a lot
of sodium, which adds water weight.
OK. Um, researchers have
studied seventh-day Adventists
for a long period of time.
And when I got involved in
research I couldn't figure
out why are you studying
seventh-day Adventists?
And the reason, as
some of you may know,
is that it's a very health
conscious population.
And by their church principles
you're supposed to avoid tobacco
and avoid alcohol and avoid
caffeine and avoid meat.
And almost all Adventists are very
good at the first three of those.
Um, so you got a huge number
of people who are non-smoking,
health conscious teetotalers,
but some of them eat meat
and some of them don't.
Perfect natural experiment.
So, uh, in 2009 the American
Diabetes Association published
these data.
They looked at -- at
body mass index.
Is that a familiar term?
Body mass index is your --
your weight, but it's
adjusted for how tall you are.
And they had almost 61,000
people and they split them
into five groups depending on
the diets that they followed.
And the first group
was non-vegetarians,
normal, typical American diet.
And their body mass index was not
below 25 as we would like it to be.
It was in the overweight
range, 28.8.
And the next group
was semi-vegetarian.
These were people who ate meat,
but less than once a week.
A little slimmer.
And then pesco-vegetarian,
what's that mean?
OK. So no meat except for fish.
And they're a little
slimmer, but -- um --
but not as slim as the
lacto-ovo-vegetarians.
Lacto meaning dairy products,
milk products, ovo for eggs.
OK. And then vegans, not
people from the planet Vegas.
Um, the vegans were the -- they
don't eat any animal products
and they were the only group
that was smack in the middle
of the healthy body mass
index range, just on average.
But then if you compare these last
two groups, I'm going to argue
that the difference between a person
following a lacto-ovo-vegetarian
diet and a vegan diet is mostly
dairy, especially cheese.
And if you do the math, that's,
what, a 15 little bit difference
from the cheese that these people
are eating just on average.
So it's really true.
When your diet is loaded with
vegetables and fruits and beans
and whole grains and you set
the animal products aside,
people have a really easy time
maintaining a healthy body weight.
OK? But I'm hooked on this.
I'm really hooked on this.
What's this about?
So, why do we get hooked?
The first thing is the salt content.
We -- we love salty foods.
People love potato chips
and French fries and things.
The other thing, though,
is it's fatty.
There's something about a
fatty, salty food, onion rings,
French fries, potato chips, that
combination tends to get us hooked.
But there is a third thing.
Anybody heard of casomorphins?
The dairy protein is called casin,
C-A-S-I-N, and casin protein,
like all proteins,
if you looked at it
under a powerful microscope,
it's a string of beads.
Each bead is an amino acid and
your body breaks those beads apart.
It goes into your blood and
your body uses these protein
building blocks.
Except casin is different
from other proteins.
That -- the milk protein casin, when
you ingest it, your body pulls some
of the amino acids out
and uses them for protein.
But other little collections
of amino acids come out as --
as little chains of
molecules called casomorphins.
Casin derived morphine-like
compounds that go to the brain
and attach to the very same
brain receptors that morphine
or heroin what attach to.
And when researchers discover
this, the question was,
"What the heck are
they doing there?"
And they've looked at many different
species of milk that -- a nursing --
a cow giving milk to her baby or
a goat or a horse or any mammal,
that milk contains protein, it
contains sugar, locates sugar,
it contains fat, it contains
a fair amount of hormones,
but it also has these little opiates
in it that we believe may be part
of the biological substrate
of the mother-infant bond.
Look -- look at a nursing baby.
They have this look of
tremendous intensity.
And then they collapse into sleep.
And you think, "Isn't
that beautiful."
You know, the mother-infant
bond is so wonderful.
I hate to say it, you --
you drug the kid basically.
Um, we now believe
there are opiates in --
well, we know there are
opiates in cow's milk.
We know they attach to
the -- to the brain.
So when I take milk, which has
a little bit of opiate in it,
and I turn it into cheese,
everything is concentrated.
It's the most concentrated source
of casomorphins you can get and some
of us call it dairy crack,
um -- be that as it may,
we believe this is why people
tend to get hooked on cheese
and especially on piazza.
Now, many people, when
they're gaining weight
and having trouble
will say, "All right.
I'm with you.
I'm going to go online.
I'm going to get the Atkins diet
and that's what I'm going to do."
And let me caution you about that.
Um, these books have been very, very
popular because they say the reason
that we're heavy is because
we're eating too much rice
and too much bread
and too many potatoes
and too many carbs in general.
And if you stop eating all those
things, you'll lose weight.
And that's true because carbs
are half of what we eat.
And if you throw out all the
potatoes and all the bread
and all the rice and all the
cookies and all the cakes
and all the fruit,
you will lose weight.
Unless you eat more of other things
so that your calorie
intake doesn't fall,
in which case you don't
lose any weight at all.
There's a whole lot of
frustrated dieters out there.
So, I'm going to suggest
that bread is not the issue.
Um, so a big problem with
this kind of dieting is
that these are the
foods that are left
when you're leaving out,
uh, the healthy foods.
And so if you tuck into these
things and your calorie content ends
up going up, you aren't going
to lose any weight whatsoever.
But even when people do lose weight,
they very often end
up with heart disease.
And this, uh, was sent to me by
a young man named Jody Gerand
who said that, "I want to tell
people what happened to me."
He happened to be in the hospital
and he had a scan of his heart
for -- that he didn't really need.
He didn't have heart disease,
but they did this scan as part
of a special physical exam
that he -- that he had.
And I'm not going to ask you
to read this, but bottom line,
he had no heart disease whatsoever.
He was fine.
And he was just a little
bit overweight,
less than 10 pounds overweight.
But low-carb dieting was such a fad,
he thought, "Let me do it that way."
So he threw out all the bread
and he followed it very --
you know, very religiously.
He was eating gravy and heavy cream,
but no bread, no rice, no potatoes.
And one day he was
walking in New York
and an elephant sat on his chest.
He had crushing chest pain.
He went into the emergency room
and he was having a heart attack.
And they did an angiogram and,
see, there's a little place
where it's all white where it
should be a -- a good artery.
He had a 97% blockage in his heart.
And his doctor said, "What
have you been doing?"
And he told them what
he had been doing.
And his diet was so high in
cholesterol and animal fat,
it's just a recipe
for heart disease.
Now, normally, when you lose
weight, your cholesterol should fall
and that often does happen.
But on about 1/3 Atkins dieters,
even though they may
be losing weight
because they're eating fewer
calories, their cholesterols go
up sometimes just absolutely
through the roof.
So he said, "Forget that,"
went on a plant based diet,
has had no trouble
keeping a healthy weight,
and his arteries opened up again.
In Australia researchers found
something that shocked all of us
who felt maybe we can
change our diet in mid-life
and we're going to be OK.
Um, they measured the thickness of
the artery wall, which you can do
in an adult and you
can do it in a baby.
And if you look at, say, the carotid
artery, which goes up to your brain,
and you do a simple
non-invasive test,
you can see how thick
the artery wall is.
And they brought and 23 women
and their brand new babies.
Within the first week of
life, it turned out that
if the mother was eating extra
food and she was overweight,
her baby was already getting
arterial thickening in the womb
that you can measure at birth.
And then if those same foods are
then part of the family's culture,
by the time that child is
18, he or she will have lost
at least vertebral artery.
And by the time the
child is in mid-life,
virtually all of them will have
standard atherosclerotic heart
disease, which we had thought
was just part of human biology.
And we now know that it's related
to food, smoking, and other aspects
of lifestyle that we can control.
So let me shift gears
just a little bit.
One of the big contributors
to heart risk is diabetes.
And if you don't mind I'd
like to spend just a couple
of minutes on -- on diabetes.
Uh, because it's a
major contributor,
not just to heart disease,
but many other issues.
In 2003 the National Institutes
of Health gave our research team a
grant to test a plant based diet not
for heart disease, but for diabetes.
And the idea was to do
a head-to-head test,
a vegan diet versus what
we called an ADA diet,
American Diabetes Association
diet that meant counting calories
and limiting carbohydrate
and that kind of thing.
Twenty-two week study.
And the test that we use
for measuring blood sugar
control is called A1C.
If you have diabetes, you
know what I'm talking about.
Hemoglobin A1C is a measure
of how good your blood
sugar control has been
for the preceding three
months or so.
And it should be below seven.
At least that's our target.
But, at the start of the study,
our people were not below seven.
They were all hovering around eight.
And the people on the ADA
diet, that's the red line,
they had an OK drop
of about 0.4 points.
That's good.
But the blue line was
the vegan group.
They had a drop in
absolute percentage terms
of 1.2 absolute percentage
points, which was bigger
than any oral diabetes medication
marketed just on average.
And it was huge.
And then we followed them
over a year and the people
in the control group ended up
getting back to where they started.
And the people in the vegan group,
some of them didn't follow
it perfectly, but on average,
they were still way better
than at the beginning.
And we had some people where
their diabetes simply went away.
And then we just looked
at their body weight.
And we found there wasn't a
dramatic difference between the two.
The red line is the ADA
folks and they lost weight.
And so did the vegans.
The vegans lost a little
bit more weight.
But the -- the important
thing here is
that the vegan group wasn't
trying to lose weight.
They were free to eat as much
spaghetti as they wanted to.
There was no calorie
limit whatsoever,
but the red line was the people
on the ADA diet where they sit
down with a dietitian
who says, "All right.
You're eating 1,800
calories a day now.
Here's your menu.
It adds up to 1,300."
"Aren't I going to be hungry?"
Yes. But it's calories
in, calories out.
You got to cut your calories
if you're going to lose weight.
"How long do I have
to stay on this?"
"Until you reach your ideal
body weight, which is never."
And the patient leaves
with this menu
and this gets old by
about Wednesday.
And you're ready to eat the sofa.
And then you start berating the
patient, "You're not compliant!
You're noncompliant!"
Who is going to be compliant
with being hungry every
single day of their life?
And instead, with the people
on the plant based diet,
they were free to eat chili.
It was just not meat
chili, it was bean chili.
There's so much fiber
in it, it's filling.
And you push away from
the table a little sooner
so your calorie intake,
it actually does fall.
But you're totally unaware of it.
Totally satisfied and the weight
loss is greater on that kind of diet
that doesn't cause hunger at all
than on a person who's trying
to muscle through it and use
discipline and wheel power.
When we want to help our
patients comply with it,
we don't use wheel power at all.
You just set up a structure
that they can't fail.
And they don't have to worry.
Is this making sense?
OK. All right.
Oh, and LDL, low density
lipoprotein, drops like a stone.
You're not eating any
animal fat at all.
It always falls.
OK. This is my most important
slide for anybody with diabetes.
I want -- I want to just
walk you through this
because I guarantee your
friends don't know about this
and your doctor does
not know about this.
Diabetes means there's too
much sugar in the blood.
That sugar is glucose.
And glucose is not bad.
Glucose is good.
Glucose powers your brain.
It powers your muscles.
The problem in diabetes is that
you've got glucose in your blood,
not inside the cells
where it can do some good.
It's building up in the
blood and you can test --
your blood tests show it.
You think, "If it would only go into
my cells, I wouldn't have diabetes."
And that's true.
Researchers at Yale
University used a special kind
of test called MR spectroscopy
where they scanned people's muscles
and their livers and
they found something
that completely revolutionized
our approach to diabetes.
This is a muscle cell.
OK? And muscles are
where most of the glucose
in the blood is trying to go.
And so you've got glucose.
It's there.
Those little dots trying
to get into the cell.
You've got insulin --
insulin's a hormone.
It's like a key.
It opens that cell up.
OK? So the glucose
needs to get inside,
but you need the insulin to do it.
So the insulin signals
these channels to open up.
And there's the glucose.
It's not going in now because
insulin let it in the cell.
But there's something
else in that cell.
See those yellow globs?
That's fat.
Fat droplets inside the cell.
And they build up based
on what I've been eating.
Doctors hate words like, "Fat."
It's got one syllable,
three letters.
So we refer to it as
intramyocellular lipid, but it's --
it's fat inside -- intra- means
inside, myo- means muscle,
cellular means cellular,
lipid means fat.
If you eat -- this comes
from food that you're eating.
So you eat chicken fat and it
goes inside the muscle cells
with very little conversion
to anything else.
You eat cheese fat or
dairy fat or fryer grease
or whatever, it's inside the muscle.
And as it goes in there, it
stops insulin from working.
The reason a person
develops diabetes is not
because they were eating
rice or eating potatoes.
It's because fat built
up inside the cell
and it makes your insulin
no longer work.
And if the insulin doesn't
work, the glucose builds
up in the blood and you can test it.
And your doctor says, "You've got
too much glucose in your blood.
You need to start medication."
Well, diabetes is not
a metformin deficiency.
All these drugs do is they try
to stimulate more insulin release
or make the cell react more.
And until the Yale researchers
scanned patients with diabetes
and found fat inside their cells,
we weren't able to tackle the cause.
So why did our research participants
who had diabetes do
better on a vegan diet?
Because there's no animal
fat in the diet at all.
And if you keep the
vegetable oils low,
do you know what happens
inside that cell?
The fat starts dissipating.
The insulin starts working again.
And you've got a shot of
getting rid of your diabetes
or having it improve dramatically
and needing less medication,
sometimes none at all, because
you're tackling the cause.
OK? So if you know anybody who's
got diabetes and they're saying,
"I'm not going to eat any
bread," take out a napkin
and start drawing my cell and
showing the fat globs inside
and that is your target, a low
fat vegan diet will cause diabetes
to start turning around.
Weight comes down.
Cholesterol comes down.
Blood sugars come down.
In some cases they are never
going to know they had it.
We, uh, did a study
recently with people
who have late stage
diabetes where, as you know,
diabetes attacks the eyes.
It attacks the kidneys.
It attacks your feet.
So that your nerves
aren't working well.
You get numb or sometimes
you get pain.
And the -- the nerves
of the hand, same story.
One of our participants
was a jazz bass player
and he had neuropathy in his hands.
And after about one or two
songs, he -- he had to stop.
He would turn his back to the
audience and just shake his hands
out to try to get his
nerves working again
and then he could play
another song or two.
Then he'd have to stop.
He came in to our, uh, research
center, went on a plant based diet
and a plant based diet,
keeping oils low too,
what does that do to the cell?
It causes that fat to come out,
the insulin starts working again,
it brings his blood sugar down,
suddenly the nerves
aren't being attacked
by that persistent high blood
sugar and narrowed arteries.
And after about two or three
months he said, "I can play again."
And he could play through a
whole set without any problem.
Two months after that
he came in and said,
"My erectile dysfunction is gone!"
So, high fives all the
way around the room.
Anyway. It's really true.
You know, that does not happen
by just filling a prescription.
Now, don't get me wrong.
Don't fire your doctor.
And there are times when
medicines are really important
and sometimes lifesaving.
But if you are not tackling the
cause and the cause relates to diet,
we just go one arm
tied behind our back.
OK. So plant based diets, they
improve cholesterol levels.
They improve body weight.
They improve blood pressure.
They improve diabetes.
And so this is the graphic
that we developed back in 2009
to summarize what a healthy diet is.
So it's fruits.
It's grains.
It's vegetables.
It's legumes.
And, by the way, we brought
this to the USDA, um, and said,
"Why don't you scrap the pyramid?"
Because in 2009 there
was the pyramid.
And the pyramid wasn't
terrible, but it had a meat group
and a dairy group and the
people who don't eat those
at all are healthier
than the people who do.
So, we said, "Get rid of them."
And, by the way, people
eat off a plate.
Give them a plate.
And we didn't hear back from them.
Um, so in 2011 we actually
filed suit against the USDA.
Um, just to compel response.
And I don't know if you saw what the
USDA came out within 20- -- 2011.
Um, I'm not taking
any credit for this,
but it does look remarkably
similar to what --
this is now called my
-- this is My Plate.
And it's fruits, it's
grains, it's vegetables.
They call it the protein
group, which could be meat,
but it could also be beans or tofu
or nuts or other high protein foods.
Doesn't have to be meat.
And there's the dairy
group, but to their credit,
they said soy milk counts.
Veganite is good.
So this is now -- that's My Plate.
This is now US Government policy.
So it's not perfect, but
it's definitely going in --
very much in the right direction.
Um, OK. Let me skip this.
I already showed you that.
So by now you might be saying, "OK.
Great. Sure.
I -- I love it.
This -- this is really going to work
great, but if I do this vegan diet,
I'm going to have to live in the
garage because my family isn't going
to want me around and nobody's
going to invite me out to dinner
and this will be impossible
and what am I going to do?"
So we break this diet
change into two steps.
I want to share it with you
and encourage you to try this.
I have never seen anyone
unable to do it.
Very, very easy.
The first step is don't
change your diet.
For the first seven
days all we're going
to do is check out
the possibilities.
So whatever you're eating, try
out things that happen to be vegan
and see if you like them.
So I take a sheet of paper and I
write, "Breakfast, lunch, dinner,
snack," on the paper and, for
the next week, you just write
down things that work
and test them out.
So, I haven't had oatmeal
since I was a kid.
Maybe with some cinnamon
and some strawberries
and blueberries maybe
it would taste OK.
Um, blueberry pancakes?
I guess I could do that
without the butter.
That's not so hard.
Um, I haven't tasted almond milk.
Hey, have we tasted almond milk?
Is it good?
All right.
OK. Fair enough.
So you know that.
You might try oat milk or
hemp milk or something else.
Just try these different things.
Same thing for lunch.
I never had a pizza without cheese.
How is it?
I don't know.
Let's see.
Um, so all we're doing for week one
is checking out the possibilities.
We go to an Italian restaurant
and the chef is more than happy
to serve you angel hair pasta
with a spicy tomato sauce
and wild mushrooms and
artichoke hearts and so forth
and pasta fazol and,
um, healthy things.
Mexican restaurant, beans and rice,
bean burritos, veggie fajitas, ah,
Chinese, they got dozens of
things, vegetable dishes,
rice dishes, tofu dishes.
Ah, extra points for Japanese
because it's often delicate and low
in fat so the veggie sushi or the
salads and so forth are great.
Um, and if you're at Subway, can
I get a vegan sandwich at Subway?
Sure. Ah, they put on the lettuce
and tomatoes and onions and olives
and pickles and so forth and
spinach and little red wine vinegar
and they'll toast it for you
and call it veggie delight.
And Taco Bell is not the pinnacle of
culinary art, but they will be more
than happy to give
you a bean burrito,
hold the cheese, and all right.
So, fair enough.
So, for the first week, I'm just
checking out the possibilities.
And then after that do three
weeks all vegan all the time,
but only 21 days because
you're just testing this diet
out to see what you think.
At the end of 21 days two
things will have happened.
First is you are physically
changing and you will feel it.
You'll have lost weight
without trying.
If you have diabetes,
you'll discover your glucose
numbers are improving.
Your energy is better.
Your digestion sorts itself out
usually within about 24, 48 hours.
You just feel dramatically
different.
Your energy is better.
Um, anybody watch the Super Bowl,
Tom Brady, as you probably know,
he threw out the cheese
a long time ago.
Aaron Rodgers at Green
Bay, same story.
They're doing this not because they
want to have a healthier figure.
They're doing this for energy
and to stop inflammation.
Um, but you -- you
will feel this even
if you're not a pro
football quarterback.
You discover all those -- my joints.
I'm better.
I feel better.
So that happens in about 21 days.
Um, the second thing that happens,
though, is your tastes change
and you didn't expect this.
But let me ask this group.
How many of you ever switched
from whole milk to skim milk?
Let me see hands.
OK. When you did, what was the
skim milk like at the beginning?
Watery? Doesn't even look right.
It's got a blue color.
How many of you adapted
to it and got used to it?
OK. Did you ever go back
and taste whole milk again?
What was that like?
It's like cream.
It's -- it's thick.
Well, wait a minute.
Your whole life it was fine.
But when you get a short
break of even a few weeks,
your taste buds physically adjust.
They no longer want the fatty
taste, but you will never have
that experience if you have a
vegan meal on Monday and then one
on Thursday because in
between you're reawakening
that fatty desire in
your taste buds.
If, just for a short period like
three weeks, you say, "I'm not going
to have it," it's like a
smoker not having cigarettes.
You forget -- you finally
forget about it,
but you crave today
what you had yesterday.
And you give yourself a 21 day break
and it gives you power
you didn't have before.
So that's why we say just do it
for three -- for three weeks.
There are transitional
foods like veggie bacon,
veggie sausage, if you want.
It's kind of like a
meat eater's methadone.
Um, you can have it if you want.
You don't have to have
it, but it's there.
Um, we have a program for you.
I want to walk you through
a couple of resources
and I'll finish with this.
At the physicians committee
we started
with something called the 21-Day
Vegan Kickstart and we start it
at the beginning of every
month as in March 1st.
And if you sign up,
it's totally free.
What you get is e-mails
from celebrities
and doctors and athletes.
We have a free app.
And every day it's menus, recipes,
cooking videos, all kinds of stuff,
and it's in English,
Spanish, Mandarin.
We have one for people from the
Indian sub-continent with, um,
English language, but
Indian ingredients.
We have a Japanese program as well.
All free. We've had more than
a half a million people go
through this so please do it.
Um, and for people with heart
disease let me recommend Dean Ornish
has a book and Caldwell
Esselstyne, you've probably --
when Bill Clinton was talking
a lot about heart disease,
these were the guys that
were always on the news
because they're the pioneers.
And John McDougall
also has been terrific.
Um, my own books, I've
got a number of them
and the Cheese Trap is
coming out next week.
Please do let your cheese
addicted friends know about that.
Um, and for any, uh, nurses,
doctors, health care people
in the audience, please
join us in July.
GW and the Physician's
Committee are teaming up now
for the 5th international
conference on nutrition and medicine
over right here at the Hyatt, uh --
Grand Hyatt, you know,
the White House.
And it's two days of everything
you need to know about nutrition
and applying it in medicine.
Um, finally, we felt that when
people come in with diabetes
or high blood pressure and
only medications are used
that we're not really
tracking the cause.
So a year ago we opened the Barnard
Medical Center to use medications
when we need to, but to go
to the cause for everybody
and that means a nutritional
approach is offered
to every -- every patient.
If you have trouble,
we don't fire you.
Uh, we love all our patients,
but we help everybody --
we have three dieticians on staff
and classes all day every
day that's all free.
And so come see us.
We're up right on Wisconsin Avenue.
We take all insurances
and it's a non-profit, um,
but it's a cool place to go.
And even if you don't want
to be a clinic patient,
we have classes for the public free.
We'd love to have you come.
OK? Um, the last thing
that I just want to say is
when people make changes, the
most important issue I think isn't
necessarily our own health.
I think it's the next generation.
When you look at kids, they're
eating foods that our parents
and grandparents never heard of.
And there are seductions on the
way home from school, on TV --
half the commercials on TV
are now for snack foods.
The other half are medications to
undo the effects of the snack foods.
And that's the world that
our kids now think is normal!
When I'm older, I'm going to
be on medications and I'm going
to eat these foods and now kids are
overweight before they get their
high school diploma.
They've got the beginnings
of heart disease.
One in three now has
pre-diabetes or diabetes.
We've got to change that.
Whether you're concerned about
the money for health care
or what really counts, which
is our families going to be OK.
Are they going to be
able to stay together?
That's why we need to do two things.
We need to experiment with
healthy foods and then we need
to make some noise about it.
But I'm not a finger
wagger type person.
It's not -- this is not
a question of guilt.
It's a question of having
fun and trying some things.
So you experiment with foods.
You find the ones you like.
If you find recipes or products
or books or DVDs that you like,
share them around and you're
going to have some duds
when you experiment with
a new lasagna or whatever.
That's OK.
That's what experimenting
is all about.
But find the foods you like.
Share them around.
Make some noise.
And I'm convinced we can change
the health of this country.
Thanks very much.
[ Applause ]
Thanks. Um, can I -- is it OK
if I take questions for
a couple of minutes?
We all right?
OK. Please?
>> I heard you say [inaudible].
And I wanted to [inaudible]
how stress also works against.
>> Neal Barnard: OK.
>> And [inaudible] diet [inaudible]
at the beginning causes
heart problems [inaudible].
>> Neal Barnard: Yes.
>> And could you say
something about that?
>> Neal Barnard: Sure.
Um, the question was
what about stress?
What role does it play?
Um, I think it plays
a couple of roles.
One is that when a person is under
either acute or chronic stress,
the body releases hormones, stress
hormones, cortisol and others.
And that these do have a
variety of health effects.
That's number one.
Number two, when you're
stressed -- is this not true?
We will eat anything just
to get through that period.
Um, so April 12th, 13th, 14th is not
a time when an accountant is going
to follow an especially great diet.
When we're stressed,
we let other things go.
So stress is -- is an issue and
you should all win the lottery
and quit your jobs and have
a stress-free existence.
Um, contrary to that, though,
in World War II pathologists
who were looking at people who died
of old age, um, were also soldiers
on the battlefield, what they
found was that those who were
under deprivation, say, like in
Belgium, places where Nazis came in,
took over, took the meat, took the
cheese, left the local population
with potatoes and vegetables,
their arteries started to clear
up even though they were,
arguably, under tremendous stress.
So I think it is good to contain
stress, but even if you have a lot
of stress in your life,
when people are
on a healthful diet,
they seem to do well.
There was a question over here.
Yes? What about oil?
Yeah. Was there a particular
issue about oil or question?
>> Um, [inaudible].
>> Neal Barnard: OK.
Um, oil is, um -- is high in
calories as any other fat.
So if a person is trying to
lose weight, we not only want
to avoid the animal fat, it's good
to keep the vegetable oils low too.
So even extra virgin -- even extra
extra virgin olive oil still has
nine calories per gram.
You remember that number?
Um, so for weight loss it's
good to keep fatty foods low
and that includes things like
peanut butter and even guacamole,
which has a lot of fat in it.
Um, vegetable oils are
different from animal fat
in that they don't have
a lot of saturated fat
that raises your blood cholesterol.
And our friends in
Spain and in Italy argue
for what they will call
the Mediterranean diet,
which is not a butter type diet.
It's more an olive oil type diet.
And they will point
to heart benefits
from the Mediterranean diet.
Now Mediterranean diet
isn't just oil.
It's also less meat,
more vegetables.
Uh, some people will argue that
red wine is a key ingredient.
Um, all these things may work
together to create health effects.
So oil is better than animal
fat, but for weight loss,
that's one reason to
keep it kind of low.
Yes, please?
>> Are you concerned about soy?
>> Neal Barnard: Um,
in -- about soy.
Is there a particular issue
about soy that you -- ?
>> Just sometimes you'll
see articles that say
that there are [inaudible]
medical, um, problems with soy.
>> Neal Barnard: OK.
I'm really glad that you
asked that because, um,
the argument goes like this.
Soy has estrogens in it that will
cause boys to become effeminate
and cause girls to
have a higher risk
of breast cancer is
what they'll say.
Um, the -- here's the truth of this.
Back in 1921 some compounds were
identified in soy called isoflavones
and they look vaguely
like sex hormones.
They are not sex hormones.
But they look vaguely like it.
And if you, however, look at
men who consume a lot of soy, A,
they are not effeminate, B, there
is no reduction in fertility
as you can quickly see when you go
to any country like China or Japan
where soy is a big part of the diet.
Fertility has not been impaired.
Um, but most importantly when
it comes to breast cancer,
there have now been I believe at
least 35 or 40 studies on women
who consume a lot of soy.
Their breast cancer risk
is cut by about 30% to 40%.
In other words, soy somehow
has the opposite effect.
And I don't know why and I'm not
even necessarily pushing soy.
Um, it's very convenient.
You know, you're better off with
soy sausage than pork sausage.
Uh, you don't need it, but
women who consume a fair amount
of soy have much less risk
of developing breast cancer.
And women who have had
breast cancer in the past,
if they consume more soy, their risk
of reoccurrence is about 30% less.
And that's important because
a lot of them are told
by their well-meaning,
but ill-informed doctor --
I read somewhere you shouldn't have
soy if you've had breast cancer
and the women who avoid soy have
the highest reoccurrence rate.
So, I'm not pushing soy,
but it -- it does --
it seems to have these
health benefits.
Time for maybe one last question?
Yeah?
>> What about supplements
like Vitamin D?
>> Neal Barnard: Ah,
excellent question.
What about supplements?
I only -- there's really only two
that I think people
should really think about.
Number one is Vitamin B12.
You need it for healthy
nerves and healthy blood
and I believe everyone
should take a B12 supplement.
Second, Vitamin D normally
comes from the sun
and when we had the good sense
to stay in equatorial Africa,
we got lots and lots of Vitamin D.
But some of us had the bad judgment
to move to places like North Dakota
where I grew up, or New Jersey
or Washington, D.C. and even if
there's a lot of sun, we're indoors.
So a Vitamin D supplement
makes sense.
How much? About 2,000
international units a day is safe.
For Vitamin B12, you
need 2.4 micrograms,
but there's no pill that small.
So any Vitamin B12 pill you
take has more than enough
and it's non-toxic even if
you swallow the whole bottle.
Um, so that's -- that's really it.
There are other supplements
sold, but they are only used
for particular applications
and mostly unnecessary.
Yes? One last question.
Sure.
[ Inaudible ]
OK [laughing].
>> I, over the years -- salt -- OK.
You got sea salt.
I've been told that you need iodine.
Is that still true?
>> Neal Barnard: Yes.
Yeah.
>> And should we [inaudible].
>> Neal Barnard: OK.
All right.
Fabulous. OK.
What a good group you are.
This -- excellent questions.
OK. You do need a little bit iodine
and there's not a lot of sources.
And it's true, there are salts
that have iodine added
to it and that's good.
It's good for your thyroid gland.
But there are also natural
foods like seaweed that have it.
So when you're going to the Japanese
restaurant with all your friends
and having the cool vegan sushi
and getting the admiration
of the serving staff, you're also
getting iodine along with it.
All right.
Well, thank you for letting
me share this time with you.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks to the organizers as well.
Thank you.
>> One of the things that I
have shared through the year
because I am a four time
cancer survivor and I have --
most of my survival has been
because I have been following
a plant based diet just
about all of my life.
And so even though I got breast
cancer, um, in the last stages
of it, um, the plant
-- the plant based diet
for me was part of my surviving.
And through the years, um,
you had written this book,
which was a good book that I've
shared with many cancers survivors
through the year because it
wasn't out when I first got it.
But this came out, I
believe it's 2008 or 2009
and this is an excellent book for
those to -- to share with others.
And even if you're
not necessarily, um,
someone that's a cancer survivor,
this book itself is a real good book
because it really basis on really
pretty much Dr. Barnard has been,
um, actually doing.
And this is the name of the book.
But he has several other good books,
but this is an excellent
book, um, to have [inaudible].
And he has some incredible, um,
recipes in here too that I've tried
through the years as well.
So Dr. Barnard, I am so happy that I
finally met one of my idols along --
I don't know if I'll ever get
a chance to meet Dr. Ornish
because I've followed him
through the years, but I thank you
so very much -- um
-- everyone -- um --
I thank you all for continuing to
support our living well, um, mind,
body, and spirit, um, Brown Bags
and we will have an exciting, um,
speaker on March 15th
that will be coming.
So look out for that as well.
So, thank you so much for your --
your coming and sharing all
this wealth with our audience.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.